[Music]
on this sunday night
loosening the lockdown in alberta
restrictions are about to ease but the
threat
is far from gone the virus is still a
scary thing
the allegations involving canada's
former top soldier that's actually very
concerning to me
did the defense minister tell his boss
about his concerns
plus a glacier burst in india's
himalayas
dozens are feared dead and the new
batman we've been waiting for
more representation the superhero
reflective of the world we live in
[Music]
global national with robin gill
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us canada has its first case of the
brazil variant and it's in toronto
the person who tested positive is in
hospital and did travel to the south
american country
these variants are worrisome as more
provinces start easing restrictions
as heather york's west reports it's
these risks that are making some
albertans worry about reopening
too soon it is a heartbreaking reminder
of how dangerous
covet 19 can be among the more than 160
cases now linked to this alamo
meatpacking plant in red deer alberta
the union representing workers says one
young employee
has died we are conducting an
investigation we know that
he was an all-email worker we know that
he was about 30 years of age
we know that he had covet 19.
the company says it's investigating the
death but outbreaks at this plant and
cargills in high river
highlight the fact that kovit 19 is
still a real threat in alberta
even as overall numbers continue to fall
with around 450 people in hospital down
from nearly 1 000 in late december
alberta will move into its first phase
of reopening monday
it includes in-person dining at
restaurants and one-on-one fitness
activities
kids sports were added this weekend
catching many in the community off guard
we learned the news on saturday morning
at 9 a.m through twitter
and it came as a surprise to all of us
in fact many of us thought we
missed something in a tweet dr dina
hinshaw said starting february 8
children and youth will also be allowed
to participate in lessons
practices and conditioning activities
for indoor and outdoor
team-based minor sports and athletics
all games continue to be prohibited
there's the potential for spread amongst
different cohorts if games occur
whereas practice sessions don't are
confined pretty much to the same
group and so consequently that's another
cautious way to proceed
dr chris modi believes alberta's first
phase of reopening can be done
safely without causing covet cases to
rapidly rise but unknowns like new
variants of the virus
have some business owners feeling unsure
the virus is still a scary thing
you know and the safety of our staff is
still of utmost
importance by fear that we would lose
out on the reopening strategy
uh with with with business and you
always fear that maybe
people may forget about you at some
point so
anyways uh it's it's damned if you do
dabbed if you don't
alberta's next phase of reopening would
include banquet halls and
conference centers and could happen in
as little as three weeks
heather urex west global news calgary
quebec will reopen part of its economy
tomorrow across the province hair salons
and museums can open their doors
universities can gradually resume
in-person classes
but the curfew will remain today quebec
became the first canadian province to
record more than ten thousand deaths
from kova 19.
there is some hopeful news
hospitalizations and critical care cases
in that province
continue to decline tonight we are
hearing from the minister of national
defense harjeet sudjan
in his first interview since global news
reported on allegations involving
the former chief of the defense staff
general jonathan vance
in an exclusive interview on the west
block with mercedes stephenson
segen says he was shocked to learn of
the allegations and is committed to a
full
investigation michael couture joins us
with more from ottawa what else did he
say mike
robin as the minister in charge of the
canadian armed forces and a former
soldier himself
harjit sajin says the most concerning
thing for him
is the confidence that has been broken
between the military and its female
members
and the women that felt they could not
come forward
that women had brought this forward
that's actually very concerning to me
sources have told global news that the
military ombudsman raised concerns with
the minister in 2018
about alleged sexual misconduct by
general jonathan vance with women
in the forces sajin refused to say
whether he told prime minister justin
trudeau or his cabinet
about those concerns three years ago he
says he wants to protect the integrity
of the independent investigation
but sajin did insist any information
that came across his desk was passed
along
to the appropriate authorities exclusive
reporting by global news
earlier this week revealed vance
allegedly had an ongoing relationship
with a woman
he significantly outranked including
while she was under his direct command
and that he allegedly made a sexual
advance over email
to a woman who was a young corporal a
senior government official told global
news on friday that the prime minister
did not know about the allegations until
it was first made public on tuesday the
canadian forces national investigation
services have
opened an investigation and interviewed
one of the women
and today the defense minister promised
a second
separate dnd investigation will be
thorough
we will be looking at who was complicit
throughout this ordeal and plus to
making sure that we get the appropriate
recommendations moving forward
to uh to make the unnecessary changes so
that finally that
women can have a feel confident that
there will not be
retribution if they come forward
vance has denied all allegations that he
ever
acted inappropriately towards any female
subordinates
robin mike like a tour in ottawa thanks
an ottawa man has been charged with
arson and mischief after a small fire
was set inside the building housing
the canada revenue agency's head office
police say a man turned himself in after
breaking a window of the cannot building
and tossing in a container filled with
gasoline the building's sprinkler system
managed to extinguish the fire
there was some water and fire damage but
no one was injured
30th daniel gru is in custody and will
appear in court
tomorrow in the u.s all eyes will be on
capitol hill this week
the second impeachment trial for former
president donald trump gets underway
tuesday
no other american president has been
impeached twice by the house of
representatives but as jennifer johnson
explains it appears unlikely the senate
will convict trump
of inciting an insurrection history will
be made tuesday on capitol hill
as former president donald trump faces
his second impeachment trial in the
senate
house managers have charged trump with
incitement of insurrection
arguing his actions led to the storming
of the capitol january 6.
when those managers walk on the floor of
the senate there will already be over
100 witnesses present
and those will be the house and senate
members senators how say you
in his first impeachment trial the
republican-controlled senate voted to
acquit the president
this time 17 republicans are needed to
join the democrats to convict him
while some doubt that will happen others
in the gop are open to hearing the case
we will now have hopefully presentations
from both sides
and we will consider the evidence as
impartial jurors
we will not take it anymore trump's
legal team has come together at the last
minute after several of his lawyers quit
they'll argue he did not commit a crime
of incitement that his words are
protected by the first amendment
and the senate has no power to try a
former president
we've never impeached a president once
they're out of office
i think this is a very bad idea both
sides are hoping for a speedy one-week
trial to get back to work on president
biden's
1.9 trillion dollar coven 19 relief
package
as millions of anxious americans await
their vaccinations
so even though there's a clear clear
discrepancy
between the demand and the supply that
will get better
as we get through february and into
march but that is the limiting factor
the biden aid package includes billions
to help schools across america
safely reopen the centers for disease
control and prevention will release new
guidelines
on how to do that this week jennifer
johnson global news
washington the u.s east coast has been
hit by another powerful snowstorm
more than 90 million americans are
dealing with either snow
rain or cold temperatures and in some
cases all of it
in new york state drivers are having a
tough time navigating roads that are
packed with snow and
then there's the blowing snow hitting
their windshields making it difficult to
see
as much as 20 centimeters is expected to
fall in some parts of the state by
tonight
in utah at least four skiers have been
killed and several others
injured in an avalanche it's one of the
deadliest slides
in the state's history canada isn't
escaping winter's wrath
there are snow storm and cold weather
warnings
right across the country on the east
coast all of nova scotia and prince
edward island
as well as parts of new brunswick and
newfoundland are under a winter storm
warning
between 30 to 50 centimeters of snow
could fall
in some places the wind is expected to
gust up to 80 kilometers an hour
from ontario to alberta environment
canada issued
extreme cold weather warnings the wind
chill will make it feel like -40
and bundle up in british columbia an
arctic air mass has engulfed the
province
so temperatures are 5 to 20 degrees
below
what it normally should be a massive
snowstorm
pounded germany this weekend some places
saw up to 30 centimeters of snow
it paralyzed transportation and caused
hundreds of road accidents
it got so bad in some cities ambulances
were unable to move through the streets
police say at least 28 people were
injured because of black ice on roads
the forecast is calling for lower
temperatures for the rest of the week
fierce winter weather forced the
netherlands to declare a code red
the weather alert is rare but deemed
necessary because of the amount of snow
the strong winds and bitter cold
temperatures it's the first major
snowfall to hit the region in 10 years
as a result many services were suspended
including train
travel grocery deliveries and covered 19
test sites at least nine people are dead
and 140 are missing
after the nanda devi glacier burst in
northern india
it triggered an avalanche and a massive
flood the deluge swept through two dams
and washed away
hydroelectric stations more than a
hundred workers
are feared dead others are trapped
search and rescue efforts are underway
in this ecologically sensitive part of
the himalayans
the glacier is located on the second
highest mountain
in the country myanmar's military has
eased a day-long internet blackout as it
contends with widespread anger over its
coup
tens of thousands of protesters hit the
streets chanting
we don't want military dictatorship we
want democracy
it's been nearly a week since the
military seized power and detained the
country's elected leader
aung san tsuchi along with members of
her national league for democracy
the military restricted communications
this weekend
an outside internet monitoring group
says connectivity in the country is at
about 95 percent
but social media sites like facebook and
twitter are still blocked
today's demonstrations are believed to
be the largest since the 2007
uprising led by buddhist monks that
eventually led
to the democratic reforms that are now
in peril
coming up the police force in canada's
largest city is putting on
body cameras but will the new policing
tool put an
end to discrimination and his claim to
fame was knocking out muhammad ali
we'll explain when global national
continues
the largest municipal police force in
canada is expanding its use of body
cameras the toronto police service hopes
to have more than 2 300 officers
trained to use the devices by the fall
the move is a big step for transparency
but as ross lord explains
there are still questions about whether
the cameras will end abuses
like racial profiling toronto police say
these newly issued body-worn cameras
will make for better policing
i just do double tap here creating an
objective account of how they deal with
the public
to look at that in a in a controlled
environment where
we can actually see if a situation
had escalated if there was a reason or
rationale
for what happened toronto police
promised to post procedures surrounding
their use
online we are also going to show the
world what our procedures are what the
operating procedure is and what the
requirements of
an officer in using this technology is
so nowhere in canada has that happened
the need for improved policing is well
documented
including two reports from ontario's
human rights commission
that found black people in toronto are
disproportionately arrested
and subjected to use of force by police
throughout my life
um i've been asked to to prove that i'm
where i'm supposed to be
whether that's um uh you know
on public transportation with the right
with the right uh
payment credentials or at an institution
of higher learning
law student and activist sandy hudson
grew up in toronto
hudson says body cameras simply
illustrate the obvious
okay we'll be able to see we'll be able
to see
more and more what we already know that
the police
harm us more than they do
other communities for example the
officers who arrested george floyd in
minneapolis
had body cams and it didn't stop the
brutality that killed him
body cameras are catching on in canada
calgary became the first major city to
adopt them two years ago
with other cities and towns starting to
follow suit
in montreal the mayor is pushing for
them suggesting they would have provided
more evidence
in a recent attack of a police officer
that ended with a black man behind bars
for six
nights before charges against him were
dropped
but in halifax where police issued a
formal apology for interrogating black
people at random
there's a cautious approach and
lingering questions
do cameras help end abuses like racial
profiling
or distract from finding solutions
cameras don't
deal with the underlying issue when it
comes to racial injustice
cameras just capture it doesn't it
doesn't
deal with the issues as halifax
deliberates
toronto is investing 34 million dollars
in the cameras over five years
a big show of faith in technology whose
ultimate value
is unclear ross lord global news
a kansas city chief's assistant coach is
under investigation after being involved
in a serious car crash
brit reid son of head coach andy reid
was involved in a multi-vehicle pileup
in missouri on thursday
three people were injured including two
young children a
five-year-old girl remains in critical
condition police documents show reed
admitted to having
two to three drinks and taking the
stimulant adderall
the 35 year old is not attending the
super bowl
former world heavyweight champion leon
spinks has died
after a five-year bout with cancer
spinks won gold at the 1976 montreal
olympics but his claim to fame came two
years later
when he beat muhammad ali for the
heavyweight title
in just his eighth professional bout
sphinx is the only boxer to take the
title away from ali
seven months later though the two met in
another match and ali
reclaimed the title leon spinks was 67.
still ahead why a new batman is breaking
barriers
for comic book diversity
you're watching global national
dc comics has debuted a new batman for
the first time in 82 years a person of
color
is putting on the cal of the cape
crusader and the writer behind this
superhero
is also black some readers see this as a
step in the right direction for ethnic
representation
as phil carpenter reports the industry
still has a long way to go
to improve diversity in comic books
at first illustrator latif martin was
skeptical when he heard about dc comics
new superhero character he thought it'd
be just another story paying lip service
to diversity
you know black is in let's cash in on it
in december the comic book giant
revealed that the next
version of batman would have a black man
behind the cowl
he appears in a new four-part comic
series called
future state the new batman once he got
a copy
martin became less cynical partly
because the character portraying batman
is so well known to long time fans
and wasn't just suddenly invented to
fill a quarter tim
fox there's a relationship with batman
with the whole lineage
of uh you know lucius fox being the
person who you know created all the gear
for him
martin is happy because the writer
behind the work
is also a man of color john ridley the
oscar-winning screenwriter of 12 years a
slave
ridley was thrilled to help evolve a
character for his kids
and other kids of color who love these
stories but just
don't quite see themselves in these
stories
that means the most to me martin agrees
that it helps for kids to see themselves
in these stories
as a black kid in montreal he rarely saw
someone
he could really relate to in comic books
and on tv
time and again i'm always disappointed
oh where's the black guy oh he's the
butler okay
where's the black guy oh he's a pimp
where's the black oh he's the thug
tara paul co-hosts a podcast about comic
books
she and her colleagues have been pushing
for more diversity in comics too
we've been waiting for more
representation that
folks that can represent us and the
superhero world
with this character though ridley wants
readers to go beyond
skin color he says the story is less
about the character's race
than his experiences as a person this is
not black batman
this is jace fox who is a person of
color who is black
who becomes batman there are those who
say that with the push for diversity in
representation comes the risk of
tokenism which some experts feel media
giants like dc and marvel
struggle with the name black often
appears in their name
their superhero name as if to say that
you know that's the defining feature
right
some have argued that even the name
black panther is an example of tokenism
i really think it's all about how the
thing is treated
and also who is behind the scenes
really agrees that diversity among the
creators is also necessary
to help make the characters more
realistic though he believes there is
room for improvement
he sees changes for the better there is
a desire
to have characters that are more
reflective
of the world that we live in making the
colorful world of comics a place
for all kinds of new characters phil
carpenter global news
montreal that story is part of a new
initiative on global called perspectives
the site features stories meant to cover
and reflect canada's diverse populations
check it out at globalnews.ca
perspectives up next canadian star dan
levy plays host and gives us more to
laugh about
somewhere my 13 year old self has
fainted in like a really needy
melodramatic way
hilarious that is canadian actor dan
levy gushing about hosting saturday
night live last night
the shit's creek star joked about
covid's safety precautions and took the
audience on a tour of the new york
studio
where he ran into another beloved
canadian
[Applause]
now i flew in i flew in to wish you luck
tonight
but because i traveled i'm now in this
high
isolation box
father and son have a lot to celebrate
these days shit's creek swept
every comedy category at the emmys it's
now in line to do the same thing at the
golden globes
and the screen actors guild awards
that is awesome and that is global
national for this sunday i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is prince albert
saskatchewan
we would love to see your part of this
country so email your photos to viewers
at globalnational.com
thank you for watching donna friesen
will be at the anchor desk tomorrow
have a good night and i'll see you next
weekend
[Music]
you